[Musique]
politique ce matin c'est à dire bonjour
bonjour si beaucoup d'être avec nous
députés la france est soumise une rente
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane vernet bonjour stéphane bonjour
stéphanie d'élite le bureau parisien de
ouest france
on commence par la crise sanitaire
adrien cattin c'est ce nouveau tour de
vis ces mesures prises pour lutter
contre l'épidémie de covile dès ce matin
elle entre en vigueur notamment à paris
et dans la petite couronne
elles ont été annoncées hier par le
préfet de policé et par la maire de
paris anne hidalgo est ce que vous
approuvez ce changement de méthode est
ce que c'est bien de laisser la main aux
élus locaux
écoutez on voit que les le les
indicateurs sanitaires se dégradent
fortement
et moi je me rappelle que à l'aube du
déconfinement nous avions dit et c'est
jean luc mélenchon la tribune de
l'assemblée nationale qui avait prévenu
l'avait dit il faut ne pas reproduire
les erreurs de la première vague en cas
de seconde vague il faudra planifier il
faudra organiser on a quand même à mon
avis vous et moi le sentiment quand on
regarde ce qui est fait par le
gouvernement d'un pilotage si on peut
appeler ça un pilotage au jour le jour
d'une forme d'improvisation qui de mon
point de vue mais en difficulté
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire le consentement
consignes qui sont données
moi je crois que les français sont dans
leur majorité disciplinée qu'ils
appliquent les consignes sanitaires
qu'ils comprennent que c'est pour se
protéger se protéger soi protéger les
autres protéger ses proches mais que
pour qu'il y ait consentement aux règles
il faut que les règles soient comprises
il faut qu'elles soient claires il faut
qu'elles soient concertés et aujourd'hui
de phrases mais les français interroge
le bien fondé de certaines décisions
c'est vrai que quand on voit qu'on va
fermer des établissements à paris quand
on va au même moment et ouvrir à
marseille quand on voit qu'on peut
chaque matin s'entasser et franchement
il faut le voir dans des proportions
considérables dans les transports en
commun mais qu'on ne pourra plus est
dans un bar très franchement les gens
s'interrogent et ils ont raison
et moi je vois que les professionnels
des secteurs impactés sont les premiers
à signifier avec vigueur au gouvernement
leur disponibilité pour établir des
protocoles sanitaires parfois très
exigeants comme ça se fait dans les
restaurants donc c'est vrai parfois il
ya deux poids deux mesures selon le
secteur d'activité
selon selon l'activité tout court qui
fait que finalement les français
comprennent plus très bien or ne pas
comprendre face à une épidémie dont on
nous dit qu'elle va durer
ça peut être problématique pour
l'essentiel limiter la circulation du
virus
on entend bien ce que vous venez de dire
mais vous n'avez pas répondu à la
question le couple préfet mère pour
gérer la pandémie c'est un bon symbole
c'est un bon c'est une bonne idée c'est
un bon échelon des dehors dès lors que
les règles sont concertés y compris avec
les acteurs de terrain par exemple les
professionnels des secteurs impactés
ça peut être un échelon effectivement
opérationnel à la condition qu'il y ait
de la concertation est pas qu on arrive
comme ce fut le cas à marseille 24
heures avant disons tout est fermé avec
les effets qu'on voit derrière cette
chance qu'on était face à lille par
exemple vous en tant que député vous
êtes vous est de consulter vous êtes
associé ou pas du tout oui bien sûr nous
avons des informations de la préfecture
qui nous arrive
extrêmement régulièrement nous avons des
échanges et csu final c'est bien c'est
vous êtes vous avez vous avez un bon
niveau l'information du point de vue de
la circulation de l'information produit
c'est plutôt pas mal maintenant on est
aussi très attentiste à lille je sais
que martine aubry a été reçue la semaine
dernière par le premier ministre et le
ministre de la santé et que pour le
moment on est dans une situation qui est
assez proche de la situation parisienne
on croise les doigts de ne pas en
arriver à la même situation c'est à dire
au passage au seuil d alerte maximale
qui veut dire par ailleurs que le virus
circule dans des proportions et du coup
par exemple à lille donc un exemple très
concret est ce qu'il ya des aménagements
très spécifique qui ne correspondent pas
ce qui se font dans d'autres villes qui
sont placés aujourd'hui en zone en zone
d'alerté renforcée non les protocoles
sanitaires y compris dans les
établissements sont à peu près les mêmes
partout regardez l'exemple des
restaurants c'est assez clair si vous y
allez vous voyez ce qui est fait est là
respect le respect de la distance entre
les tables le fait qu'on limite la
circulation au sein des établissements
qu'on porte le masque quand on quitte sa
table donc des choses qui en tout cas
moi me donne le sentiment plutôt d'être
en sécurité dans cet établissement vous
avez un regard particulier ou une
inquiétude particulière sur la situation
des universités notamment puisque à
partir d'aujourd'hui les amphis les bien
pensants testo lui il doit y avoir
moitié moins d'étudiants danser dans ces
lieux est ce que ça va avoir un impact
sur les étudiants que ça aura un impact
moi je j'observe effectivement l'impact
qu'il ya sur toute une génération qui a
d'abord subi les effets du confinement
y compris à l'école dans l'enseignement
qui va aussi subir les conséquences
d'une crise sociale qui est un véritable
tsunami du point de vue de l'emploi à
huit cent mille jeunes sont arrivés sur
le marché du travail qu'en cette rentrée
dans un contexte où le chômage s'accroît
de manière considérable donc oui je peux
m'inquiéter pour cette génération et je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de solutions y
compris en termes de relance économique
qui ne sont pas à la hauteur que le
gouvernement que le gouvernement en
place et les mesures les mesures pour
les jeunes spécifiquement dans le dans
le plan de relance sont insuffisantes
pour vous notamment la le la prime à
l'embauché de 4000 euros pour les pour
les jeunes de moins de 25 ans ça s'est
passé pas une bonne idée ça me paraît
très insuffisant et surtout on voit
qu'il n'y a pas de traduction directe
entre par exemple certains contrats
d'apprentissage qu'on a extrêmement
développé et l' embauche derrière moi
j'en sais quelque chose et j'ai été
moi-même apprentis et je peux vous dire
que dans la promotion dont je faisais
partie
le taux d'embauché des apprentis qui se
sont investis pendant deux ans dans une
entreprise il n'est pas du tout garanti
donc c'est une solution disons à très
court terme et moi je pense qu'on
pourrait faire bien d'autres choses
notamment pour relancer véritablement
l'emploi et l'activité
je pense qu'ils sont là les vrais sujets
et je vous le dis ce n'est pas en
faisant pleuvoir des milliards sans
vision stratégique sans contrepartie et
sans cohérence de la part du
gouvernement avec ce plan de relance qui
en quelque sorte une sorte de crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi géant
or maintenant on connaît les bilans du
cic eux et c'est catastrophique en point
de vue de création d'emplois je crois
que ça n'est pas suffisant mais
peut-être qu'on va parler d'économie
chats on va en parler dans quelques
secondes juste une question puisqu'on
apprend juste non excusez moi juste une
chose à laquelle je pense on a eu
pendant toute la première vague le
problème des masques ils étaient
indisponibles et donc on me disait
qu'ils étaient faussement protecteur
voire inutile ce même monsieur edouard
philippe lui-même promis nice qui disait
cela
aujourd'hui il ya du stock l'épidémie
dur le l'obligation du masque c'était
attendu quasiment partout je redemande
au gouvernement séance tenante de
procéder à la gratuité du masque on
demande de le changer plusieurs fois par
jour pour une famille avec deux enfants
c'est un budget mensuel de quelques un
peu plus de 200 euros ça n'est pas
tolérable il faut la gratuité des
masques et j'observe que désormais à
l'hôpital public on me dit que
maintenant on a plus de problème pour se
fournir en masse mais figurez-vous qu'on
a un autre problème maintenant c'est les
gants on a expliqué que pour avoir une
boîte de 100 gants jetables à l'hôpital
parfois maintenant faut attendre dix
jours pour la recevoir
donc je j'observe hôpitaux
dans beaucoup d'hôpitaux apparemment je
pourrais pas généraliser mais il y a un
vrai problème on peut le creuset il ya
un vrai problème avec les gants et faut
il faut effectivement ils travaillent et
donc
j'observe une chose c'est que le
gouvernement visiblement n'a pas tiré
les enseignements de la première vague
entre guillemets et qu'il qui n'a pas
planifié qu'il n'a pas organisé qu'il
pilote au jour le jour dans une forme
d'improvisation qui je le crois nous
sommes en danger
dernière question sur cette crise
sanitaire puisqu'on apprend selon une
étude de ms est que plus d'une personne
en grand une personne sur deux en grande
précarité et est infecté par le cos vide
en ile de france
on imagine que ça vous inquiète mais
évidemment il ya un lien entre des
situations sociales terribles qu'on a pu
voir et compris au printemps dernier et
la circulation de l'épidémie c'est très
clair moi je m'inquiète par exemple que
dans le plan de relance du gouvernement
il y ait si peu pour soutenir les plus
précaires 0 8% du budget sont consacrés
à l'aide directe aux plus démunis ce
n'est rien vous avez vu ce rapport du
secours populaire la semaine dernière
qui est désastreux
la situation de la pauvreté dans notre
pays est à un niveau qu'elle n'a jamais
atteint depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale on parle de cela
le secours populaire a vu pendant la
période du confinement un million deux
cent mille personnes alors que sur toute
l'année 2010 neuf c'était 3 millions et
nous disent que 45% des personnes qui
sont venues solliciter l'aide du secours
populaire net était inconnu de ses
services et moi je veux dire une chose
c'est qu'il y a un lien entre
l'extension de la pauvreté
la france est un pays riche dans lequel
il y a dix millions de pauvres et il y a
un lien entre l'extension de la pauvreté
et lippert accumulation entre quelques
mains parce que de la même manière que
je vous dis que la pauvreté s'est étendu
pendant cette période vous avez
peut-être vu ces chiffres ahurissants
qui montre que sur la même période celle
du confinement de mars à mai les 25 plus
grandes fortunes du monde ont accru leur
fortune entre mars et mai de 255
milliards d'euros 13 mille euros par
seconde savez c'est comme le disait le
poète un victor hugo c'est de l'enfer
des pauvres qui est fait le paradis des
riches et ça je crois que c'est un vrai
sujet qu'il faut aussi traiter le
partage des richesses injustement on va
parler de ce plan de relance 1 vous êtes
assez critique en tout cas dans ce que
vous me dites il arrive
avec le budget qui arrive à l'assemblée
lundi prochain est ce que quand même ce
plan de relance vous vous dites bon
c'est mieux que rien on va aller voter
quand même ces mesures non parce que
regarder un peu la philosophie générale
bon d'abord on nous dit à 100 milliards
c'est un effet d'affichage
beaucoup de ces milliards ont déjà été
dépensés lors des précédentes lois de
finances rectificatives d'une part
surtout nous dit à 40 milliards qui
doivent arriver de l'union européenne
dont je voulais tout de suite on n'est
pas prêt de voir la couleur parce que en
réalité non seulement la france compte
tenu de du niveau auquel elle est
contributrice au budget européen dans
cette affaire elle va devoir payer
davantage qu'elle ne va recevoir mais
surtout et bruno le maire -ministre de
l'économie et des finances l'a confirmé
il nous a bien expliqué que ces 40
milliards était en quelque sorte
conditionner plus ou moins en tout cas
c'est ce qu'il dit à des réformes
structurelles et parmi les premières
réformes qu'ils citent comme réformes
structurelles il y à la réforme des
retraites si on pense que dans un tel
contexte social n ya pas vraiment les
deux chômage sur ce plan de relance
regardez prévoyez tout le monde conteste
cette idée mais c'est bruno le maire
lui-même qui nous a expliqué qu'il y
avait des conditionnalités au déblocage
le fait que la commission européenne
regarderai que les états appliquent des
réformes structurelles et la première
que le gouvernement décide de citer dans
le lot de ces réformes structurelles
c'est la réforme des retraites
je reviens sur les 100 milliards est
favori mais c'est la philosophie
générale de ce plan de relance qui ne
fonctionne pas je le disais c'est un
cice géant le cic eux qu'est ce que
c'était le fameux crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi
il en a coûté 20 milliards d'euros par
an au contribuable français pendant cinq
ans tiens donc ça fait 5 milliards ça
fait 100 milliards vous souvenez qu'à
l'époque quand françois hollande l'a
instauré le patron du medef pierre
gattaz portait un petit pin ce qu'ils
voulaient nous vendre un million
d'emplois
un million d'emplois dont nous n'avons
jamais vu la couleur au contraire c'est
plutôt un million d'euros de dépenses
publiques par emploi créé compte tenu de
ce que le cic a créé comme emploie
environ 100000 pour une raison simple
faire pleuvoir des milliards sans
contrepartie sans vision stratégique
sans planification ne crée pas de
l'activité est ce que l'on vérifie
actuellement à l'aune de cette crise
sanitaire
c'est que bien sûr il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui sont en difficulté
qu'il faut soutenir des tpe des pme des
artisans des commerçants mais que
voyons-nous par ailleurs des profiteurs
de crise des grandes entreprises qui ont
les reins solides qui ont touché à plein
régime pendant des années dette publique
est où là
la transmission est allé directement des
poches du contribuable français aux
poches des actionnaires
c'est le cas des bridgestone c'est le
cas des hauts-champs d'écart guile et
toutes sortes d'entreprises et je vous
invite à aller voir le site cac a
réalisé un syndicat stop aux
licenciements point fr c'est une
hécatombe social sur le barça c'est la
régie stone mais sur ceux sur ce budget
qui est assez vrai des chiffres hors
normes il ya plus de 6% déficit de 116 %
de dette est ce que vous dites c'est pas
grave c'est le contexte c'est la crise
qui veut ça ou est ce que quand même
vous dites c'est un vrai problème
d'avoir de tels chiffres de la dette et
du déficit alors je vous dis une chose
très claire et je vais droit à deux buts
avant même cette crise sanitaire les
dettes des états étaient déjà impayable
et tout le monde le sait est aujourd'hui
parce qu'elles ont augmenté dans des
proportions considérables
quelques personnes et quelques libéraux
qui étaient pas d'accord avec cette idée
le disent eux aussi
il ya donc des solutions tranquille
pacifique pour solder ce problème parce
que je vous le dis quand le gouvernement
ait compris encore par la voix de bruno
le maire nous explique que l'avenir du
pays ça va être de rembourser la dette
par la croissance et la production c'est
à rebours de tout ce qu'il convient de
faire notamment face aux grands défis
qui se présentent devant nous celui du
changement climatique irréversible
il va falloir investir en plus
considérablement pour solder ses grands
défis donc il y à une solution
tranquille qui a été d'ailleurs réalisé
outre manche on a vu le trésor
britannique ce qu'il faisait ce que
faisait les américains avec la fed
il faut que la banque centrale
européenne rachète directement aux états
les titres de dette et elle peut les
classer c'est un peu technique pardon
dans ce qu'on appelle la dette
perpétuelle comme ça l'économie repas
sur d'autres bases c'est notre souhait
est ensuite la dette c'est face au fur
et à mesure si ce que nous disons aux
générations suivantes
c'est vous allez devoir payer la dette
je vous lis tout de suite tous les
objectifs que nous devons atteindre en
matière de changements climatiques
en matière de relance de l'activité ne
seront jamais atteints mais si la bce le
fait pas alors qu'est ce qui se passe si
les objectifs sont jamais atteint et
c'est pour vous le scénario c'est quoi
quand on s'endette à ce point si on peut
pas rembourser
mais c'est de toute façon comment ça se
permet tout le monde sait que ces dettes
sont impayables donc c'est la solution
que je propose c'est la seule solution
qui soit en quelque sorte que nous
proposons elle est pacifique elle est
tranquille sinon qu'est ce quelle autre
solution pour être si l'on connaissait
il ya par exemple les guerres moi
franchement je le souhaite pas il ya des
situations qui sont catastrophiques
on peut faire les choses tranquillement
soit en la classant dette perpétuelle
soit on
condamne les générations futures à
devoir simplement pas d'alternative
alliés pour ben vous en connaissez une
moi non non mais ça veut dire que le
discours sur justement l'heure où on va
rembourser on va n'en tire la dette
c'était qu'on va rembourser à très long
terme et on la perd à sur les fruits la
reprise économique vous n'y croyez pas
ça m'a absolument bas compte tenu qu'ils
compris du principal danger que nous
avons devant les yeux le changement
climatique voyez la situation que nous
connaissons actuellement deux phénomènes
météorologiques extrêmes dans le sud-est
ou en bretagne
nous le savons les scientifiques le
disent ce type d'événement est appelé à
se multiplier
donc ce sont des solutions d'entr'aide
de planification ce sont d'autres
valeurs qu'il s'agit de mettre sommet de
la hiérarchie des normes nous pouvons le
faire
notre pays a tous les atouts pour le
faire mais certainement pas avec pour
objectif de rembourser une dette par la
croissance économique c'est à dire
simplement d'utiliser le vieux logiciel
vous parlez beaucoup de planification
c'est un terme que vous avez utilisé à
plusieurs reprises depuis le début de
l'interview et c'est vous si vous aviez
eu à gérer ces 100 milliards vous le coq
est ce que vous auriez créé comme
conditionnalité comment vous l'auriez
planifiée comment est ce que vous auriez
utiliser cet argent alors c'est marrant
parce que vous aviez pendant la campagne
en affaires on la présentait justement
et j'invite toutes celles ci nous en
nous et les grandes lignes bien sûr pour
l'essentiel ce que nous disons bon 100
milliards c'était la somme que la france
insoumise ceux proposés dans la dernière
campagne présidentielle d'injecter dans
ce que nous appelons la planification
écologique donc l'échelle l'échelle de
valeur est la bonne
bah oui mais c'est après c'est ce qu'on
en fait et puis surtout le fait qu'ils
aient une part de ce budget je viens de
le dire dans ta priori n'est pas prêt de
voir la couleur ok conditionnée au fait
que nous fassions des réformes que nous
ne voulons pas que les français
d'ailleurs refuse également notre plan
de déconfinement économique pour une
bifurcation écologique nous l'avons
proposé il y a quelques mois il est
toujours on peut toujours le trouver sur
le site internet de la france est
soumise c'est un document assez épais
mais je vais le résumé en peu de mots en
gros notre idée c'est nous n'avons
toujours pas nous ne renonçons pas au
plein emploi malgré ce contexte et nous
voyons de grands objectifs d'abord face
au chômage de masse nous disons qu'il
faut diminuer le temps de travail et
nous voyons que du côté allemand le
puissant syndicat de la métallurgie
allemande a mis ce débat en circulation
il faut assumer de dire qu'il y a un
problème de création d'activité pérenne
qu'il existait déjà avant la crise
sanitaire vous savez par exemple
qu'avant le coc vide
80 % des embauches qui étaient réalisés
dans d'autres pays 80 % étaient des
embauches en contrats courts des
contrats parfois de moins d'un mois
parfois de moins d'un jour
ils font que de manière très rapide vous
sortez les statistiques du chômage mais
la réalité sociale n'est pas
profondément modifiée donc assumons de
dire que face au chômage de masse
partager le temps de travail est une
solution raisonnable sérieuse pour
pouvoir créer de l'activité et ensuite
en gros c'est travailler moins pour
travailler mieux et travailler tous
voilà l'objectif est ensuite c'est de
dire que nous voulons effectivement face
aux changements climatiques
irréversibles engagé une bifurcation
écologique par la planification et je
vous demande de réfléchir un court
instant monsieur castex nous promet en
cent soixante mille emplois avec son
plan de relance de 100 milliards
je crois que c'est beaucoup trop cher et
qu'on peut créer de l'emploi a moins
cher que ça si vous regardez ce que nous
proposons dans la planification
écologique cite quelques exemples la
transition notre modèle agricole passer
d'une agriculture intensive en chimie et
industriels à une agriculture paysanne
relocaliser l'économie de la mer la
transition énergétique les transports ce
sont des choses non seulement
passionnante à faire enthousiasmant que
je le crois mais surtout qui permettent
de relever le défi climatique et de
créer de l'emploi
les quatre secteurs que je viens de
citer on a chiffré ce que l'on pourrait
créer avec la planification écologique à
1,5 million d'emplois admettez que c'est
beaucoup plus que ce les 160000
proposées par monsieur kassai hun
derniers mois la tune sur bridgestone à
vous en avait parlé tout à l'heure il ya
eu une marche 1400 personnes qui ont
marché dimanche pour s'opposer à la
fermeture de cette usine de bridgestone
à béthune c'est dans votre région et on
en est à ce qu'elle ait eu des avancées
sur ce dossier à ce que le gouvernement
fait ce qu'il faut il ya une discussion
qui est prévu en ce début de semaine une
nouvelle discussion savez sur
bridgestone il faut nommer les choses
simplement à quoi avons nous affaire
nous avons affaire à une délocalisation
intra européennes avec les aides et la
bénédiction de l'union européenne et de
l'état français puisque en effet que
s'est il passé
bridgestone le groupe japonais a décidé
d'abandonner le site de béthune dessous
investir et d'investir dans le même
temps en pologne et en hongrie avec les
aides et les subventions de la fameuse
europe qui protège comme le dit manuel
macron pendant que de l'autre côté il
rayer d'un trait de plume le site de
béthune voilà donc faut dire les choses
et quand j'entends monsieur castex sur
une chaîne de grande écoute
il ya quelques jours en prime time nous
dire que le problème de bridgestone
c'est que le groupe aurait mal investi
lui dit monsieur castex vous faites une
erreur fondamentale si vous vous situez
du point de vue des actionnaires de
bridgestone
ils ont parfaitement agi ils ont investi
en pologne avec les aides de l'europe et
abandonner un site qu'ils ont voulu
laisser de côté et c'est tout bénef pour
les actionnaires donc moi en fait si
vous voulez dans ces dossiers qui
s'accumulent sur mon bureau dans les
noms dont les noms changent
auchan etc mais dont les recettes de
cuisine qui sont appliqués à ces
salariés sont exactement les mêmes
j'en ai marre je le dis j'en ai marre de
voir l'état avec sa sébile en train de
déplorer et de demander la petite pièce
à des groupes qui sont par ailleurs
extrêmement riche et de voir l'état
complice ou un minimum à minima organisé
son impuissance
on peut faire des choses je cite des
exemples parce que je vais être concret
l'état peut refuser des plans de
licenciement si la motivation économique
n'est pas fondée peut refuser de les
homologué par la voix de la direccte
l'état devrait dans la loi exigeait
désormais qu'il y ait des contreparties
sociales environnementales aux aides qui
sont versés par exemple dans le futur
plan de relance
et quand des entreprises sont prises la
main dans le sac d'une courroie de
transmission qui va directement des
caisses de l'état aux poches des
actionnaires sur le dos de salariés
licenciés nous devrions exiger le
remboursement
et cet argent devrait être réinvesti
pour le maintien dans l'emploi voilà
j'en ai assez que l'état organise son
impuissance et sa complicité face à des
groupes qui franchement ne mérite pas
autre chose que d'être mis au diapason
par l'état français
allez on va continuer à parler de votre
région mais sur un autre sujet on va
parler des régionales stéphane est ce
que vous aurez les candidats dans toutes
les régions et est ce que lesquels et
quelles sont vos intentions pour la
région de france alors notre feuille de
route nationale est assez claire les
insoumis ont voté pour un texte qui
propose de s'adresser à toutes les
formations politiques qui sont en
rupture claire avec la politique qui
monsieur macron et son gouvernement pour
faire pour faire clair nous avons
adressé un courrier à l'ensemble des
formations de gauche en dehors du parti
socialiste
non pas que nous voulions absolument pas
discuté avec des socialistes mais nous
observons à l'échelle du pays y compris
dans tous ces seigneurs adriq turc l'air
de l'appareil je vais vous dire une
chose
on parlait de bridgestone à l'instant
aller voir les salariés toutes ces
entreprises et vous verrez que la plaie
du quinquennat précédent
allez allez on peut le déplorer est là
encore très présente notamment sur le
cic j'aurai des vous et pour répondre à
la question vous aurez vous aurez des
candidats dans toutes les régions
on est en train d'organiser
cette d'avoir des chefs de file partout
mais nos chefs de file savent que nous
recherchons des accords nationaux avec
d'autres formations politiques sur une
base programmatique qui est claire nous
voulons instaurer à l'échelle des
grandes régions un bouclier social et
sanitaire
nous voulons engager avec les moyens des
collectivités la bifurcation écologique
à l'échelle de ces territoires et nous
voulons aussi démocratisé ces
collectivités qui pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens représente pas grand chose
en clair aux chefs de file des deux
listes
évidemment c'est une condition et dans
toutes les assemblées générales de la
france est soumise du moment c'est ce
que nous faisons maintenant j'observe
que dans la discussion pour obtenir un
cadre national la france insoumise qui
met beaucoup sur la table de souplesse
auprès de ses partenaires potentiels
rencontre parfois quelques crispations
et quelques volontés hégémoniques qui à
mon avis sont pas à la hauteur du moment
comment ça vanne car elle nous savons
qu'à gauche où nous avons des désaccords
mais je pense que certains de ses
désaccords ne sont pas traitées dans le
cadre des départementales régionales
donc que dans beaucoup d'endroits on
devrait pouvoir discuter vous avez cité
les hauts de france
moi je pense par exemple c'est dans les
rues france ça fait cinq ans désormais
qu'on a un face à face entre l'extrême
droite de madame le pen et la droite de
monsieur bertrand en face à face qui
objectivement a fait perdre beaucoup de
temps à la région le volontarisme
affiché de monsieur bertrand sur
l'emploi n'a pas produit les effets
qu'on pouvait en attendre
et en matière écologique par exemple ça
a été un recul
impressionnant donc je crois
effectivement que les différentes forces
qui sont présentes avec bien sûr les
associations les syndicats les ong les
collectifs citoyens devraient pouvoir et
c'est le sens de l'appel que nous avons
créé ce fédérer nous avons appelé à une
fédération populaire pour les hauts de
france et d'ailleurs on peut signer cet
appel est le retrouver sur le site
internet que nous avons lancé ce
week-end qui s'appelle hauts de france
populaire au plurielles.fr et ce face à
face dont vous parlez entre
xavier bertrand et marine le pen je
schématise il a lieu parce que la gauche
s'est retiré en 2015 pour empêcher la
victoire du front national est ce que si
la situation se reproduit en mars 2021
la gauche se retira à nouveau ou cette
fois vous dites on se maintiendra coûte
que coûte ce qu'il faut d'abord souhaité
avant tout c'est que la gauche soit peu
en situation de devoir procéder à cela
et qu'elles soient suffisamment fortes
pour faire son retour dans ce conseil
régional voilà je pense que vous savez
ce qu'on voit scrutin après scrutin
surtout et je trouve que trop de
formation politique ne tire pas de
conclusion c'est l'abstention
grandissante
on l'a vu aux dernières partielles
parfois 90 % d'abstention il ya des
bureaux de vote vous peut être en tête
avec un résultat en valeur absolue qui
vous même vous permet même pas d'être
délégué de classe dans une école non
mais c'est pour vous dire un peu le
niveau de l'abstention
donc ça c'est considérable et pour nous
ce que nous lisons situation se produit
siens face à face entre les seynois
d'abord s'il vous plaît faire en sorte
que la situation ne se produise pas j'en
ai assez de cette fatalité aussi alors
je crois que il y à il y à une nécessité
à mobiliser parce que l'abstention vous
le savez touche en particulier les
jeunes les employés les ouvriers les
milieux populaires
on en a assez des élections sans le
peuple ça devient un suffrage censitaire
les élections donc il faut agir pour
lutter contre et la france insoumise se
dote de méthode pour le faire
très justement dernière question sur la
place que vous allez occuper ou alors la
place que m mais j'avais une autre
question là d'une annonce récit serait
candidat ou pas à la présidence de la
république en octobre on est en octobre
des nouvelles il avait dit effectivement
qu'il prendrait une décision il ya une
décision vous la connaissez sa décision
et écouter la nav en avance dans la
prise de décision mais il ya une
décision qui est politique et une
décision aussi qui est personnel je vous
demande de l'entendre campagne
présidentielle surtout dans le contexte
que l'on a c'est assez violent
maintenant j'observe une chose jean luc
mélenchon a dit qu'il se sentait une
vocation de candidats communs et
j'observe au vu des sondages même si un
sondage à 18 mois d'une présidentielle
pour le prendre avec beaucoup de
pincettes mais j'observe qu'il est
plutôt bien placé pour jouer ce rôle est
donc j'interroge nos partenaires une
bonne fois pour toutes puisque vous ne
cessez de raconter qu'il faut à tout
prix un candidat commun à gauche quel
est le problème avec jean luc mélenchon
pourquoi pas lui quel est le problème
avec le prime de la france en sont mises
parce que souvent on discute dans le
vide mais nous nous avons un projet à
mettre en discussion et nous ne disons
pas à nos partenaires c'est à prendre ou
à laisser ce n'est pas vrai mais
l'avenir en commun ce programme répond
de notre point de vue a beaucoup des
enjeux
il a recueilli 7 millions de voix la
dernière présidentielle discutons-en de
quel chapitre voulais vous parler
quels sont vos contributions que peut-on
améliorer mais un moment donné je crois
y compris que se dégagent au vu des
sondages permet de dire que oui jean luc
mélenchon serait un bon candidat pour
réaliser cette tâche et surtout dans les
milieux populaires qui va falloir
mobiliser
je ne sais pas si beaucoup des noms qui
font couler beaucoup d'encre en ce
moment vont pouvoir mobiliser mais je
sais que dans ces milieux-là le nom de
jean luc mélenchon évoque quelque chose
et est une force propulsé l'autre
dernière question est ce que vous êtes
candidats pour les régionales pour mener
ces combats à gauche à titre personnel
non moi je ne le suis pas mais mon
collègue bernalicis a signifié sa
disponibilité
bien qu'encore une fois nous discutons
avec toutes les forces en présence et
notamment avec fabien roussel et patrick
kanner et notamment avec fabien bref
c'est effectivement
merci beaucoup merci aimerait bien nous
ce matin merci stéphane venne et regarda
une nouvelle france stéphane laforest au
pied du mur climatique c'est à lire
aujourd'hui dans ouest france merci
messieurs on passe ce tuto club de
territoire la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires
angie acteurs engagés dans la transition
zéro carbone et région vous présente le
club des territoires
[Musique]